le lion tous et c'est toute une région
automobile qui s'arrête avec la
fermeture ce matin à 5h de l' usine psa
de sochaux
les mesures de confinement verrue aussi
l'économie des sous traitants et des
intérimaires
le groupe psa en lui-même n'a pas
forcément une santé trop fragile il
s'est bien refait où j'ai plus de crin
c'est pour l'ensemble des petites
industries du nord franche-comté où là
effectivement certaines auront peut-être
du mal de remonter la pente
on parle d industrie mais on parle de
tout ce qui va autour des industries et
là effectivement il y aura peut-être
d'agacer il va falloir que le
gouvernement l'a aussi trouvent des
solutions à audincourt le sous-traitant
flex and get fabrique des avions et des
pare chocs pour la 3008 ou l'opel
grand'landes x dans cette usine
la plupart des 1000 salariés sera mis en
chômage partiel une nécessité qui a une
influence sur le salaire est inquiète
les salariés pour les personnels cadres
ya pas de problème puisque c'est à 100%
par contre pour les non cadres
aujourd'hui leurs réglages habituels ses
84 % du net
on avait cru comprendre jeudi soir comme
monsieur mâcon garantissait 100% et on a
l'impression que fayez hier soir ce
n'était pas tout à fait le même discours
donc
monde attend de voir mais ce serait
quand même bien que le gouvernement
fasse un effort là-dessus pour les rues
urbaines la situation économique risque
de se tendre si le confinement perdure
les collectivités territoriales comme la
région bourgogne franche comté ont
promis de mettre la main à la poche pour
aider les nombreuses entreprises et
salariés du secteur automobile
là c'est très dense autour de du groupe
et ça c'est à peu près 200 entreprises
qui vont qui sont touchés a minima et
puis pratiquement vingt mille personnes
et qui sont un petit peu en arrêt ou
liés à cet arrêt d'activité
on espère que les mesures annoncées par
le gouvernement vont pouvoir palier on
va dire à corriger ces problèmes
en espagne sa faillite très vite même
situation compliquée pour les agences
d'intérim débordé il faut annuler les
contrats à clore l'émission en cours
les contrats qui sont clôturées ben ça
dépendra du des droits de chômage
habituel et concernant les contrats en
cours ce sera le fameux
chômage partiel auquel président dans le
président nous a parlé hier soir voilà
et qui s'applique aussi aux intérimaires
qui s'applique également aux
intérimaires donc à la maison ou
derrière le masque le pays de
montbéliard retient son souffle
comme partout en france chacun espère
que l'apnée ne durera pas trop longtemps